[MUSIC PLAYING]
JILL DOLAN: I don't think people
who aren't LGBT can
quite imagine what it feels
like to hear the lyrics of
"Old Nassau" and feel both
inside and outside of the
University's anthem.
Can they imagine how it feels to
hear, tune every heart and
every voice, bid every care
withdraw, sung at alumni day
or after a basketball game, and
want to tune your heart to
the song's invitation to
community, but to wonder
whether your voice
is part of the
every to which it gestures.
Living an invisible subcultural
life in a school
like Princeton, which takes such
pride in its traditions
of belonging, is heartbreaking
to contemplate, and to many
LGBT alumni, painful
to remember.
BILL THOM: A recurring theme
is the sense of isolation,
that you were the
only one world.
AMY CAMPBELL: We separated
our work life from
our personal life.
And as long as we did that,
the secret was safe.
HELEN ZIA: Being in my early
20s then, I just was like,
OK, how do I answer this?
Am I a lesbian?
ALICE MILLER: I used to go to
the university bookstore and
flip through abnormal psychology
books to try to
identify something that looked
like how I felt.
KAREN KRAHULIK: I thought, well,
gee, if I have a chance
of being straight,
it's probably
going to be at Princeton.
GARY KING: I can only point to
one member of my class who I
knew at the time I was an
undergraduate who was out as
an LGBT student.
KAREN MAGEE: It was very
much of a kind of
secret society, almost.
GARY KING: When it comes down
to writing a history or
researching a history for a
group, which may, in a lot of
people's minds, be an
invisible group.
I think it is a challenge.
BILL THOM: When I entered
in 1959, we were
10 years from Stonewall.
Nobody I knew either there or
anyplace else for that matter
was openly gay, man or woman.
ALICE MILLER: I've never heard
of another trans person there.
There has to be statistically.
And I used to like to think
I was the first woman to
graduate from Princeton.
But I don't really
believe that.
The university in those days
was a couple hundred years
old, and there has to have been,
even if nobody knew what
transsexual was and is.
PETER LIGHTE: In certain ways,
there was nothing easier about
sexuality than there was about
classical Chinese.
And both were dispatched,
I'm happy to say, in an
environment that let
that happen.
But it certainly wasn't
a walk in the park.
HELEN ZIA: For being at
Princeton in those days when
there was so much activism,
there was also so much
homophobia.
I think there was,
not just for me--
I'm sure everyone who might have
come out or might have
been questioning at that time
was also subject to the same
homophobia that was there.
GARY KING: One of my classmates
was the head of the
Gay Alliance of Princeton
during our time there.
On his freshman year dormitory,
he hung out a
banner for the Gay Alliance
of Princeton.
So if anybody was walking across
near Wilson college,
there was no way you could do
this huge Gay Alliance of
Princeton orange and
black banner.
Early in the second semester,
the room was vandalized.
So people broke into the room,
vandalized the room, took the
banner, and tore the banner, I
mean, just tore it to shreds
There was a full
investigation.
Any of the students who were
found who broke into the room
were suspended.
So there was reaction from the
university that this kind of
action will not be tolerated
by the university.
We will not tolerate
vandalism.
We will not tolerate going
into anybody's room.
And we will not tolerate any
prejudice against any of our
student body.
SUE ANNE STEFFEY MORROW: I'm Sue
Anne Steffey Morrow, and I
became associate dean of the
chapel and religious life.
I think for some of us it's hard
to imagine, but maybe not
for others of us, is how deeply
closeted the students
were at Princeton.
KAREN MAGEE: Thinking back on
it, I don't think the world at
Princeton back in the late '70s
and early '80s was much
different than the
world at large.
I mean, there weren't a lot of
people that were out at that
point in time anywhere.
TIM WU: I came to Princeton
in 1980.
And that was a time when the
campus was really just
starting to embrace the ideas
of difference and diversity.
It was a new paradigm.
SUE ANNE STEFFEY MORROW:
We wanted to reach
out to the gay students.
But where were they?
And when I came in the fall of
'81, I talked, I asked, I
asked around.
And it took me time to discover
that in fact, there
was a small group that met in
the dark, back corner of the
Murray-Dodge Cafe.
The first meeting I went to,
there may have been four or
five undergraduate men there.
The lesbians met in the women's
center, which was in
Aaron Burr Hall on
the second floor.
KAREN MAGEE: I was very involved
in the women's center
when I was at Princeton.
So there was certainly a
community around that.
SHAWN COWLS: The role models
there were the handful of
students who are brave
enough to be out and
outspoken and known.
One professor who was openly
gay, Michael Cadden, was
definitely somebody
I looked up to.
KAREN KRAHULIK: I'm Karen
Krahulik, class of 1991.
I wrote my senior thesis
on gay and
lesbian marriages, which--
god, I don't even know how I
knew about them, but I knew
that they existed.
I loved doing this work.
I loved going out there, finding
people who had been
married, finding the ministers
who had performed the
marriages, investigating
the legal aspects,
the historical aspects.
SUE ANNE STEFFEY MORROW: I
officiated at the first gay
marriage in the university
chapel.
SUMAN CHARKRABORTY: When I was
at Princeton, and because we
were such a small community,
we really wanted to
be noticed on campus.
We wanted the issue of closeted
students and support
for out students to be something
that the campus was
thinking about and that
the administration
was concerned about.
And we used to have events
throughout the course of the
year in order to make
that happen.
Gay Jeans Day was one of them.
And the message was simple--
if you support the LGBT
community, wear jeans.
On the college campus, where
most people wear jeans, that
was a tough message to sell.
We used to have a Gay
Jeans Day rally
right outside the chapel.
And people would be
furious with us.
They'd say, how can you put a
message on something I wear
every single day?
For us, it was the
conversation that it was starting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMY CAMPBELL: Over time, building
upon those quiet
conversations, when the LGBT
Center came along and the
strength of Debbie Bazarsky and
the folks in her office
really created a climate where
it was much safer and where
LGBT students across campus
were welcomed.
[APPLAUSE]
SHIRLEY M. TILGHMAN: Hi.
Thank you.
I can't tell you how happy
I am at this moment.
This is really a dream come true
to have this center here
in the Frist Campus Center, but
more importantly, to have
so many people here
celebrating that
we have such a center.
I think all of you know that
none of this, and I mean none
of this, would have happened
without Debbie Bazarsky.
[APPLAUSE]
DEBBIE BAZARSKY: When I first
arrived at Princeton in 2001,
there were very few out
students on campus.
I could actually name and count
the number of students
on my hands.
There were very few students
in general that were out.
And a number of students I met
chose to come to Princeton
because they thought it would
make them stay in the closet.
They could have gone to more
liberal or open institutions,
but they thought that Princeton
would keep them closeted.
I feel like we've come from that
place to the place where
we are today, where we have 50
or 60 out students coming to
campus already out every year.
And we have a really vibrant
community on campus.
TOBIAS RODRIGUEZ: We should have
a space like that, but we
also shouldn't take it for
granted, because there are
many other colleges that
don't have it.
We're one of the few that has
that and has a lot of
programming come out
of it every year.
SHEHZAD UKANI: It's incredible
to think that in 1972, someone
release an ad in The Prince
about "Closet Queens Unite!,"
and it's come to becoming
an entire center.
And I really feel indebted to
so many people because of my
very, very positive experience
that I've had with a large
part of my Princeton career
here, particularly to
President Tilghman, who is the
reason why we have a center in
the first place.
COLE CRITTENDEN: For me, what
was really terrific about
Princeton is that it felt like
this inclusive and supportive
place from the day I arrived.
KAREN MAGEE: I had the
opportunity to serve as a
trustee with both Harold Shapiro
as president and
Shirley Tilghman.
And I think both Harold and
Shirley contributed in
enormous ways to making
Princeton the place that it is
today, making sure that all
alumni felt welcome there.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: What has Shirley
Tilghman done for the
gay and lesbian community?
What has she done for the gay
and lesbian community?
I suppose just about as much as
one single individual can
do for a community.
SHIRLEY TILGHMAN: This is, I
think one of the most dramatic
cultural changes that I'd ever
experienced in my life, which
is the change in people's
attitudes toward LGBT
individuals.
So I think Princeton has
benefited from that.
But I think it is also
attributed to the fact that we
now have three members of our
cabinet who are openly gay and
have, I think signaled to the
rest of the University
community that this is a place
where LGBT individuals can
really thrive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]